en este vídeo lo que buscaremos es para
el concepto de que son las fracciones y
más que dar lo que lo entiendan de una
manera mucho más sencilla pensemos por
ejemplo
que tengo una pizza voy a dibujar una
pizza
consideren que
esta es una pizza perfectamente redonda
de verdad que estoy buscando que sea lo
más redonda posible ok
esta es mi pizza y esta pizza la voy a
dividir en partes iguales en cuatro
partes iguales
este sería
la mitad y estaría dividiendo en dos
partes iguales
y de esta manera la partiría en cuatro
partes iguales así es que la idea de las
fracciones es que todas las partes son
iguales tengo cuatro rebanadas de pizza
de igual tamaño y digamos que mi vida
tiene queso
suave pizza tiene que eso
hoy se me hizo algo la boca
aunque esta es mi pizza con queso en las
cuatro partes iguales pero sólo una de
ellas tiene aceitunas pondré mis
aceitunas en esta parte solo una
rebanada tiene aceitunas
si a mí me preguntaran qué fracción de
tu pizza tiene aceitunas será lo
siguiente estaremos hablando de que
tengo cuatro partes iguales estamos de
acuerdo tengo un total de cuatro partes
iguales
y de esas cuatro partes iguales sólo una
tiene aceitunas
puedo decir entonces que un cuarto de la
pizza tiene aceitunas
un cuarto
la pizza
aceitunas
y este es el concepto de la fracción
sólo una fracción una parte de ellos
tiene las aceitunas cual pues un cuarto
sólo una parte de un total de cuatro
tiene aceitunas vamos a ver otro ejemplo
qué fracción de mi pizza tiene sólo
queso únicamente que eso así es que
pensaré en tengo un total de cuatro
rebanadas idénticas cuatro rebanadas del
mismo tamaño y una dos tres cuatro
tienen queso pero sólo tres
tienen queso como único ingrediente esta
ya tiene aceitunas no la contaré
así es que diré que tres cuartos de mi
pizza
tiene únicamente queso
solo que eso
vamos claros la intención es tener algo
dividido en porciones iguales y poder
diferenciar entre ellas voy a hacer un
ejemplo con animales no mejor con frutas
las frutas son más sencillas de dibujar
para mí
tengo por ejemplo una naranja
se pueden ver tengo una naranja vamos a
dibujar qué tal una y una lima una lima
es una lima
cítricas
y qué tal que tengo un plátano
este es un plátano
tengo un plátano vamos a dibujar una
manzana
yo camino
roja
y finalmente haré un racimo de uvas
vamos a considerar este racismo como
toda la unidad ok
un racimo de uvas
porque estas son mis frutas si a mí me
preguntarán qué fracción del total de
mis frutas es amarillo contaría primero
el total de mis frutas tengo una dos
tres cuatro o cinco frutas tengo un
total de cinco frutas
ok un total de cinco frutas cuántas de
ellas son amarillas
tengo una 2
dos quintos de mi fruta
son amarillas
va quedando claro el concepto dos piezas
del total de cinco dos de cinco son
amarillas en este caso vamos a hacer un
ejemplo más y pensemos que tengo
una barra de chocolate
este es mi barra de chocolate
perdón creo que ya es
hora de la comida y por eso estoy
poniendo tantos ejemplos con comida
veamos tengo mi barra de chocolate la
cual está partida si los han visto que
tienen así diferentes
diferentes bloques
pensemos que tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 bloques
seis bloques mi barra y yo tengo mucha
hambre como en este caso y me como
estos dos bloques
qué fracción de mi chocolate me he
comido
vamos a colocar tengo un total de 1 2 3
4 5 6 bloques
y de esos seis bloques yo me he comido
estos dos
pues porque tenía mucha hambre así es
que dos de esos seis bloques me los he
comido en cuanto a fracciones diremos
que dos sextos dos bloques de seis
totales dos sextos
me he comido dos sextos de mi barra de
chocolate
me he comido
espero sea claro el ejemplo finalmente
lo que buscamos son partes iguales y ese
es nuestro total una rebanada de las
cuatro totales que tengo tiene aceitunas
tres de las cuatro rebanadas únicamente
tienen queso y aquí por ejemplo dos de
las cinco frutas totales son amarillas y
aquí dos de los seis pedacitos totales
de mi barra de chocolate me las he
comido los invito a que tengan este
concepto en la cabeza porque es uno de
los conceptos más prácticos que van a
poder tener en la vida las fracciones
piénsenlo mucho practiquen y los invito
para que se metan en la página de khan
academy y practiquen con los ejercicios
que tienen ahí ok es súper importante
este concepto las fracciones nos vemos
en otro vídeo